[Music]
hello everyone my name is Suresh FL and
for the past 10 years have been a
product manager at Google I'm based out
of a country called Sweden which
apparently is very popular around here
these days I've I've had the amazing
opportunity to be part of a journey and
throughout these 10 years and this
journey of course wasn't done only by
myself but with many colleagues that are
here in the room with me today and for
the duration of those 10 years so for
everyone please wave there you go and
some I'll invite them up front those
that I can help in answering your
questions later so a bunch of the people
here in the room have helped built what
I'm going to present here today let's
take a look back at 2007 10 years ago a
decade feels like a longer time than if
you say 10 years and can anyone here in
the room tell me something that happened
in 2007 do you remember the iPhone
anything else George Bush another good
one my my son reminded me was that the
last Harry Potter book was published in
but what I thought of as well was the
iPhone and if you look at the iPhone
today you can see that a lot of the
design aspects of the iPhone in 2007
have kept which is you know a true
hallmark of of of the design but we all
know that behind the scenes the services
that power the infrastructure that power
all the software all the hardware has
changed tremendously and that made me
think of Google in 2007 when I joined
and this is how the homepage greeted you
in 2007
and the fonts a bit dated
the the logo we know has changed but if
I switch to 2017 you'll notice that even
the same words are used advertising
business about privacy term settings the
layout the I feel lucky is still there
the microphones new but things have
things have been fairly consistent but
as we all know Google behind the scenes
has changed a lot as well in ten years
and if we look at how Google was in 2007
well Google had just gone from being
3,000 employees in 2004 to 17,000
employees by the end of 2007 so when I
joined I joined it at just at the cusp
of a period of extreme growth and today
Google is about 71 thousand employees
that was end of year to 2016 and what
was different about how Google grew was
that Google grew globally and we didn't
just open offices in countries for
having a sales presence we opened
offices to have an engineering presence
and so back in 2007 we already had 42
offices across the world and not just
sales sales presence in the countries to
do local business but engineering
presence so Google was one of the is one
of the few companies that really
invested in a global engineering
presence from very early on talent was
global we wanted products to be made
closer to our users and have that input
so it's really helped at building a very
diverse engineering workforce so where
we were in all these offices a company
growing
and everyone very ambitious to build
great products and to to transform the
world and to change the world but we
couldn't do it the traditional way a
traditional way of doing global
engineering means very heavy processes
very long planning cycles things that
you can't change on a whim
and you know maybe I should have showed
concrete instead of a bunch of wires
tangled the word process in my head
always means this but we wanted to be
able to work globally but still be
creative be innovative be agile it'll
hear that word often in engineering we
tried these guys we tried the phone
every employee had a phone bridge number
and a pin we hated it it was bad quality
it was hard to know when it's your turn
to speak there's no queues how do you
know when it's your time to come in you
have these long awkward silences
and it was just too hard to understand
people and it didn't it didn't promote
creativity at all and then I took a
snapshot of my inbox last night and I
don't maybe I don't need to explain too
much here but emails great we overuse
email we get overloaded by email it's
sometimes hard to get answers quickly
and it's also very hard to to to
understand each other and when you're a
global workforce spoke in speech written
speech tone what you actually mean how
people perceive what you mean gets
tricky in written form and so while we
got far with email it didn't carry us to
our goals
so one thing caught on at Google and
very early on videoconferencing seemed
like a great way to distribute a
workforce
it seemed like a great way to promote
agility creativity and to build that
team feeling so Google's founders really
early on decide to go for it and they
went for it in a big way
they the Google started to deploy
Tandberg video conferencing units across
the world here's how a room looked like
in 2007 this was a typical Google room
this one was from our Zurich office and
you can see the mass of wires on the
table the camera bolted to the wall all
the technology was in the black cupboard
there on the left side of the screen I
don't know what was in the fridge next
to it that little grey fridge but let's
just say it was water but a room like
this would cost anywhere between forty
and eighty thousand dollars in equipment
in installation costs remember every
time someone has to come up with a drill
that's when the installation costs start
to decline to climb heavily but we had a
lot of these units by the end of 22 2007
we had over 2,400 rooms like this around
the world and these were powered by
infrastructure complex on-premise
infrastructure and this was not for the
faint of heart on the left side of the
screen you'll see a MCU and this is
where all these rooms would connect into
every one of these an MCU by the way is
a multi-point control unit but it's
really a bridge it's something that
mixes all the video and audio together
and we had a massive mix of these MCU
these gatekeepers these failover
gatekeepers these border controllers to
allow meetings with a
Journal outside of Google meetings and
as I said this was not for the for the
faint of heart every one of these MC use
could connect 480 rooms dialing in each
room using up one port each port cost
four thousand US dollars if you wanted
to have 720p video we got really good at
this imagine being able to deploy 2400
of these rooms the world's biggest
Tandberg deployment not only in amount
of rooms deployed but in the amount of
minutes used these systems were used
around the clock we use them to have
team meetings we use them to have our
scrums or our age agile stand-ups using
video conferencing informally became
part of our culture because these
systems were everywhere
and yes you even got to meet your boss
who was around the world somewhere else
every week and look him in the eyes or
look her in the eyes every day if you
wanted so slowly but surely vici made
Google more nimble on a global scale and
then we broke it we had to go and ruin a
great thing we ruined it because it
couldn't grow with us we had reached the
maximum capacity of what a system like
this could do and we tried but people
wanted to dial in from home the software
that we use to dial in from home it was
written by the same people that had
written those conference rooms those
conference rooms were connected with
dedicated Ethernet they had a dedicated
part of the network they had quality of
service monitoring when you're at home
on your home Wi-Fi or your DSL line the
conditions are completely different so a
software couldn't just couldn't connect
properly the calls would get dropped the
audio the video were horrible everyone
dialing from home would use up one of
those $4,000
so then you'd have 15 people dialing in
from home and if there's no more ports
available it means your 20 person room
that you just paid $80,000 to install
couldn't connect to the meeting because
all the home folks would compete with
them these were real issues I remember
these from these bridges I remember one
of them catching fire and we knew
everyone knew how expensive those things
were everyone knew that Google just had
meetings after meetings after meetings
so I remember this could be a legend but
I remember a Google field tech having
oven mitts pulling out a card that was
on fire to save the bridge instead of
going at it with an extinguisher but
that's dedication and again if one of
those cabinets filled up and you only
had four ports left and you had a 10
person meeting things would fail
inexplicably
I also remember having to have engineers
from the various companies we were
buying products from on-site in
California and they were at our offices
for very long periods of time probably
charging by the hour and I always
remember them because they were always
the ones renting the fancy rental cars
at the airport you know the big orange
or the big orange Mustang that that's
always there and says it could be yours
for $150 more a day these engineers that
we that we were flying in to help us it
would always drive the fancy Mustangs
and they would work and work and work at
trying to get our system to scale and we
couldn't get there so what happened we
decided that it was time to innovate so
Google pac-10 the management team was
called the operating committee and they
made an important decision they said
we're not gonna buy this stuff anymore
it's done it's over Google is going to
go from 17,000 employees to much
more and we're probably going to grow
quicker than what this is these systems
can offer anyhow we need to build at
scale and this means that the you know
the pressure was on so what follows is a
bit of storytelling about how different
innovation tracks happened some
simultaneously some serially and some
building off on top of each other the
first one was to build for scale so here
is the video chat in Gmail let's see if
we can get some audio I did this video
in November 2008 took me ah eight hours
hi I'm Serge and I helped develop Gmail
voice and video chat from Sweden our
team works closely with a team in the US
so video chat comes in really handy some
things are just better communicated
face-to-face where you can see
expressions gestures and I can point
things out on a diagram plus whenever I
travel I get to see my kids so let me
show you how this works gmail voice and
video chat is integrated right into
Gmail so it's very easy to use to start
a voice or video chat simply click on
the video and more link at the bottom of
the chat window when a person receives a
call they'll hear a ring and they'll see
a notification that they can choose to
answer you can pop out the chat window
and adjust the size and positioning as
you like you can even make it go
fullscreen through a single click it's
free and easy to use
visit gmail.com slash video chat to get
started if ever someone asks you to
volunteer for something like that
think twice what's important here so I
had been working with software video
conferencing for 10 years so I started
around 97 and we had a small company and
in 10 years we were able to get 200
thousand users and we were all proud
when we launched this thing the two
hundred thousand user mark passed in a
few hours it is amazing the scale at
which
Google operates and having all these
users with all these different firewall
settings and all these different
networks and all these different cameras
and audio card and trying to support all
of them was an amazing challenge but we
learned a ton from it
so building at that scale helped us
understand how to how to cater to many
many many scenarios let's see if I can
go forward here no I'm sorry about that
I need to click on the white area
perfect
oops so we started from with Gmail video
chat and then we went to whoops the
video started playing in the background
please don't make me hear myself again
and this was all fine one-on-one
conversations but we wanted to replace a
Tandberg experience we wanted to give
group video meetings so we have an
engineer in in Sweden and a UX designer
who was based out of our Kirkland office
Jake Knapp they had been thinking a lot
about this and it was pretty obvious
very very quickly that we wouldn't be
able to do full-blown group video
conferencing inside of Gmail so we did a
little we did a little sandbox play area
where we started to play with with the
software in different ways and these two
individuals came to the Epiphany that
hey why don't we just tie an actual
meeting or a meeting room to our URL and
so we built a prototype and we called it
go meet and say hey let's go meet infu
go meet foo and that caught on and
people thought hey this is neat great
and this led to something called go meet
that we were using internally at Google
in 2009 and this is another prototype
Arthur has not aged lucky him and you'll
see some of the people on that screen
are in the room with us today
and we launched this to Google in 2009
and it became it picked up it became a
big success people could work from home
the latency was a lot lower than those
video bridges that had to transcode
there was no transcoding in this system
and people could take meetings from
their desk they couldn't take meetings
from home they could take meetings on
the road and so there was a there was a
moment where this started to grow
quicker and the Tandberg rooms were
being used less and less and this became
Google Hangouts a little bit later on
one thing that's that was different with
this back in 2009 is video is on by
default you went into a meeting go meet
hang out or go meet foo and video was on
and that was an important pillar for
this software experience because if you
have if all these people would join and
you'd all be sort of avatars and the
audio-only who's the first person to
dare show themselves on camera in front
of all these others right who's that
conceited person that's going to be the
first one to say hey I'm so great I'm
gonna show myself for everyone and so
those system didn't work the ones that
didn't have video on by default straight
from the start they don't work for
building team culture this created it
created a sense of team and after a few
times you don't care about your hair or
the mess the kids made in the background
because if this is your team this is
your safe space these are the people you
create with this is a people you build
software with our second innovation
track was about the stock building video
communication software was a real pain
back then you had to license third party
software not just surf third party
technology but a third party audio stack
a third party video stack and then you
had the fun part of taking to two
different technology
from two different companies put them on
top of your own Network stock and then
fit this into a plugin remember the
plug-in architecture is called NPAPI the
N stands for Netscape just this is
something people forget and you needed
the plug-in for Mac Windows and Linux
and you needed to have a great flow for
deploying these plugins but also for
keeping them updated so how do you
update a plug-in how do you download the
plug-in so it doesn't affect the call
how do you update the plug-in so you
don't tear down a call that's going on
and how do you do that in a browser
without the actual software page being
showed up because that's usually where
these things were get triggered very
tricky and with one of the best install
flows we had that you could find on the
Internet we still had first first
attempts to join a meeting failures of
about 30% people just cannot it's just
too hard to download software on your
desktop and find that file run the
Installer completely installer remember
that restart the browser because this is
a plugin people would fail at joining
their meetings a first time all this
complexity of deployment and having to
integrate other people and other
companies technology meant that
innovation stagnated and quality was a
hard thing to improve when you're not in
control of your own stack so the team at
Google started a project called WebRTC
WebRTC is an open source audio and video
platform that developers can use to
create video and audio communication
apps it's available on Chrome Android
and iOS and there's other browsers that
take the code and implement it in their
own browsers
it's a open source community effort with
different standard bodies it's highly
secure and in chrome this is a one-click
experience there's no more download you
click and you're in your meeting that
helped a lot of users
and it's not a stretch of the
imagination to say that WebRTC today
powers video conferencing on the
Internet
if use Google Hangouts Google duo
facebook Messenger GoToMeeting Twilio
the list of companies is over a thousand
long of companies that integrate WebRTC
the code that Google wrote and Google
made available for creating web for
creating video conferencing experiences
so now we had started building software
then we decided that we wanted to own
this stock we wanted to understand how
audio and video works we wanted to make
that part better but we still had Google
Chrome
growing like crazy in all these meeting
rooms that needed video conferencing
support and so this is a video of two of
my colleague Steve Taurus and Eric ng we
bought a HP TouchSmart in 2008 and
that's the one we bought this ran
Windows Vista it ran Firefox and
something called grease monkey if any of
you remember this it would grab the
video chat little bubble that you saw in
that video and it would make it big so
that you didn't know gmail was there in
the background and with the touch screen
it allowed you to punch in a meeting
name it cost $1000 as a thousand 50
instead of several thousands of dollars
there were no remote controls or devices
this was an all-in-one and so this was
our first attempt at creating a video
conferencing room set up by ourselves
I will project a kiosk a PC to function
as a tamper replacement so I'm gonna
go ahead and part on digs you hit dial
it will go directly to this page that
will show you a video conference that
you'll join in progress this was on the
first time if it all worked just like
talk video and that was it the actual
meeting the actual videos like 15
minutes long because it was powered by
this time it took so much time to boot
but so you know the team did there was
so much work that needed to be done
after this first proof-of-concept right
we move this to Linux we redid the
front-end we we we had to do fleet
management on this so that we because we
wanted to deploy thousands of these but
that little video those two individuals
and the others that worked with them led
to a revolution at Google we built a
video conferencing appliance and so this
is today at Google and all of our
meeting rooms have video conferencing
and they're all built on top of the same
software that I just talked about
hangouts and WebRTC it's powered by by
computers that run that run in Chrome OS
today we're going to talk about that in
a little minute but we've got over
15,000 rooms today that have video
conferencing capabilities so this is one
of their offices in Tel Aviv here's an
office in London this is a smaller
huddle room and this is how good we've
become at choosing the cables passing
the cabling the amount of discipline and
thought that has gone through all of
this is just staggering because when you
have to do something
15,000 times across 70 offices now or 70
countries now
you can't let anything to chance so what
cables are you use how do you pull the
cables what holes you drill
what boxes that you choose to insulate
sound from the PC and all those things
are really really important and we put
that ubiquity to use so today if you
look at our usage at Google we've got
Googlers dialing into a video meeting
230,000 times a day for a company that's
about 71 thousand employees we spend
nine point two nine point three years of
time every day in video meetings and
this is not just meetings this is again
a team that is distributed that wants to
feel that feeling of togetherness it's
people that want to have one-on-ones
it's teams that want to have their daily
scrums or their Huddle's and it's people
that just want to have a virtual
presence maybe they're working from home
that week and they want to feel close to
their team so they're just on video and
the rest of the team follows suit and
again we've got over 15,000 of these
rooms internally at Google and then
everyone has their laptops and their
phones and the same experience that they
have in the room moves to the laptop and
moves to the phone it's a very important
detail in this case because you don't
want to create islands of communication
if you have a different room system than
what you use on your laptop and then
what you use on your phone when you try
to bring all of these together you
create kind of separate islands of
collaboration and the lowest common
denominator of the experience you know
it just makes everything dumbed down a
lot and I don't know what happened but
you see the company since 2013 doubled
in size but the video minutes in the
system have gone up 17 X so as the
company grows you've got
kind of social graph that just explodes
and people want to share experiences
share knowledge and and just make sure
that everyone is up-to-date and the
whole company can make decisions quicker
thanks to it and I think this is what
makes Google one of the unique company
because we can do global engineering and
I think you can see it taking off now
there's a fourth track to all of this
and it's a little product called
chromebox for meetings the same team
that built the beautiful deployments
that you saw a few years ago understood
that ubiquity was very important they
wanted to be able to scale things up to
much more than 15,000 rooms I've heard a
rumor that there's expectations that we
add an extra 20,000 rooms over the next
two years to our system and that team
understood very quickly that having a
computer having to pass all these wires
and maybe was a level of complexity that
was too high to be able to scale up to
those numbers so the team sat down and
created a system that would also cater
to our customers needs because our
customers have as large deployments as
we do some of our customers beat us in
the amount of minutes they do per
employee out there it's incredible to
see the power of ubiquitous video
conferencing and what it brings to a
company a Chrome OS machine that is
secure there is nothing more secure than
a Chrome OS computer on the market today
because of the way the hardware is
signed to the software and vice versa a
computer that allows you to do remote
management of it very easily
and this is why Chromebooks are so
popular in schools and in enterprise
because of this remote management
capabilities
a computer that connects to your
calendar to your room's calendar and all
it does all day is it shows your room's
calendar and it's waiting for a click
it's just sitting there waiting for a
click and when someone clicks boom
you're in the meeting and that's that's
that's about the amount of interaction
it gets when you share when you want to
share a document to your meeting you do
it over Wi-Fi from your computer you can
you know you can mute yourself you can
hang up the call and you can start the
call and everything comes from from the
Google Calendar so it integrates really
well with G suite and we really believe
that this is the next step to our
ubiquity project and we're working
really hard at evolving this for not
only for growing Google's video
conferencing culture but also bringing
our customers with us on the journey so
expect a lot of great things on this
front a little bit later this year so
finally today you could say that thanks
to all this work and all this innovation
and ten years of sweat and tears we've
been able to support a video a global
engineering culture that fits into what
Google is it spans the globe it saves
time it helps Google make decisions
quickly it helps people share ideas help
each other and be able to try to reach
some kind of work-life balance if you
need to work from home you work from
home there's no need to commute in every
day and and now this is a tool that is
evolving based on your feedback and the
input that you've been giving us as
customers and you might wonder what
happened to our Tandberg systems and
when I was looking at this last night I
found a web page from a team in
Australia that recycled them and created
PlayStation 4 kiosks with them
and apparently apparently the the shape
of the ps4 fit perfectly in that cabinet
and and they became very popular in
certain countries as PlayStation 4
enablers so on that thanks for listening
[Music]
you